[Musique]
gérald darmanin a acté un renforcement
des contrôles de 30% après le couvre feu
de 18h le ministre de l'intérieur s'est
rendu dimanche 31 janvier au péage de
buchelay pour assister aux vérifications
des forces de l'ordre
l'élection de trappes annulé le tribunal
administratif a remis en cause le mandat
d'al hira b il lui est reproché d'avoir
utilisé son association coeur de trappes
pour promouvoir son image pendant la
campagne ali rabais a fait appel de la
décision auprès du conseil d'état
tony estanguet président du comité
d'organisation des jeux olympiques 2000
24 est venu à la rencontre des jeunes au
vélodrome nationale pour la semaine
olympique et paralympique
des animations étaient organisées tout
au long de la semaine sur les différents
sites yvelinois des jo de paris
pas de record pour les premières
injections de vaccin c'est ce qu'a
annoncé la rs ile de france cette
semaine
trente-deux mille doses pfizer et
moderna ont été commandés pour les
yvelines cela représente environ 3853
dévoue maintenu les taxis de saint
germain en laye ont été mobilisés pour
faciliter les vaccinations surnommé
levac si ce service gratuit a été mis en
place avec la mairie afin d'emmener les
personnes âgées se faire vacciner
enfin la crue de la seine sous
surveillance après avoir été placés en
vigilance orange le week-end du 30
janvier le département est redescendu en
jaune en début de semaine pas de
véritable urgence pour le moment
[Musique]